free for all at america's southern
border a group of migrants crossing into
the u.s were spotted wearing
biden please let us in t-shirts and
while the white house refuses to call
what is going on
a crisis a leaked memo says border
agents are being
overwhelmed according to axios hundreds
of unaccompanied minors
are being taken into custody on a daily
basis and border patrol is struggling to
deal with the skyrocketing number
okay i'll start with you first jesse you
know it's kind of interesting
that you've got all these people coming
into the border with these
biden t-shirts and and the issue is are
these desperate asylum seekers
or is this part of a coordinated effort
and if they're desperately seeking
asylum
uh where did they get the biden t-shirts
yeah i want to know who manufactured the
t-shirts maybe i'll have an
investigation on the weekend show
but i know this judge the cartels are
getting filthy rich
i'm beginning to think hunter might be
on the payroll if you're a parent
in central america you pay a coyote five
grand to get your miner across the
border
and once they're across because of the
amnesty promises
and all of the other soft border
policies
they bring back the chain migration and
then that whole family can come through
so if it's five grand a child and
they're expecting a hundred and
000 migrants child migrants to come
across this year
that's a half a billion dollars in the
pockets of the drug cartels
the drug cartels control mexico
obrador's not in charge
they're in charge and now their control
of our southern border
you don't think everyone that comes
across adult or minor
owes something to those cartels they
know who their families are
and when they tell that illegal
immigrant once they get to chicago or
long island
i need you to do this i need you to do
that they'll do it or else they'll kill
their family back home
cartel's owned this country at this
point and joe biden's
letting him do it all right well dana
i mean what what is the excuse for you
know
loosening up the restrictions on
illegals in terms of
covid and yet you know the criticism
that we just talked about in the
previous block
of any any governor who wants to kind of
you know
get rid of the mass mandate as a as a
legal requirement
i mean it's it's it's counterindicated
so looking at this as an outsider it
seems to me that none of this was very
well thought through except for that
um it definitely was let's do something
the opposite of what president trump was
doing
and there were some things that maybe
you could have done better but here's a
i brought a list
for jesse on on a few things um the one
of the first things was
promising an eviction moratorium that's
one thing that will happen
uh ending the remain in mexico policy
that was actually a good policy
and the mexicans were participating
and then when all of a sudden that went
away so now that mexicans don't have to
do that anymore
they nominated a health secretary health
and human services xavier becerra
uh the attorney general from california
who wants to be hhs secretary
he advocated for free health care
for illegal immigrants when he was in
california that's one of the reasons
that his nominations
hit a little bit of the skids in the
senate and he if he gets pushed through
by the democrats he will be the first
one
that ever goes without a majority vote
in the committee
and i think that's partly it because if
you start to tell people oh you
get to do all of these things plus you
are going to get free health care that's
not going to be a deterrent
two other things on my list um the
offering the life saving covered
vaccines
to them now the white house has said no
but there's enough out there that you
think well something is going on there
look i'm not saying that all people all
humans should have access to the
vaccines but should
americans be first i think arguably you
could say yes um
and then working to defund the border
security measures or basically you know
saying that the wally and juan calls it
a fictional wall
do it with the wall i think in border
security again it's the maslow's
hierarchy of knees that's the foundation
that you need to do all the other stuff
that you want to do
and juan you know what they're saying
the illegals that are coming in
is they are demanding that president
biden
keep his campaign promise to lighten up
and to change the laws
as it relates to illegal immigrants
don't you think that's uh
you know that's rather presumptuous
yeah and i think they'd be wrong judge i
mean what i recall is
you remember that scene at the
democratic uh debates where i think it
was
uh julian castro said that he wanted to
decriminalize
illegal crossings at the border and then
they asked every
democrat on the stage to raise their
hand if they agreed everyone raised
their hand with one exception
joe biden he wouldn't do it so to my
mind they got the wrong guy
and also remember that all the criticism
from the left of the obama bide
administration for arresting and
deporting
criminal illegal immigrants so i think
that's a these are facts
i mean i think you know what we're going
to likely see some kind of spurt and
across things that uh
you know come the springtime and even
now with the unaccompanied miners
but this has been consistent over the
last 40 years
you can go back to bush clinton bush
obama
during the last they're breaking records
juan yeah it's true
remember you guys you guys were beating
me up about 2018. you said there was a
caravan yeah i mean
this is all so when trump tried cruelty
like separating
families at the border thank you
why are they there so then thank you
what is it if that was a caravan what
does it make this
go ahead greg well no i the the
separation of families is a very
interesting point
given that where are the families now
that was a narrative
that still hasn't been justified when
you were talking about a hundred
thousand
teens uh coming here and the parents
suddenly have disappeared
it makes me think that four-year
narrative about separating families
tearing children from their parents
was a load of huey and that's the
technical phrase
i have a suggestion for americans
tomorrow you saw those t-shirts they
were really well made
i mean they had the biden slogan and it
said let us in
those are really well made shirts
tomorrow go make your biden shirt
biden joe let us
out let us go back to work because if
they
because i would like to see that being
treated every bit as seriously as this
topic
is and again it comes down to the fact
that the people making these decisions
don't have any skin in the game none of
the uh illegal aliens coming across are
going to take their jobs if anything
they'll be working at their house
so they don't care they don't care but
there are people on the lower rungs
of our our employment ladder who are
going to lose their jobs
which will be taken later by people who
cross the border we know that
it's happened